we introduce apparent ridges for
non-photorealistic line drawings they
are view dependent extensions of region
Valley lines given an object a viewing
screen and a projection from the object
to the screen we define view dependent
curvature as the change in normal of the
object as one moves a small distance in
the screen
note that this value increases towards
the contours because it takes for
shortening of the object into
consideration here we see curvature and
view dependent curvature color-coded
onto the object the warmer the color the
higher the value on front-facing parts
of the image the two values are similar
when the object turns away from the
viewer the view dependent curvature gets
much larger apparent ridges of the
extrema of this view dependent curvature
we compare apparent ridges to other
lines apparent ridges are related to
ridges and valleys where ridges and
valleys do well apparent ridges are in
similar locations where ridge and valley
lines are too rigid and boxy apparent
ridges modify them to be closer to the
contours
while rich and Valley lines are fixed to
the surface apparent ridges slide
smoothly along the surface apparent
ridges are red ridges and valleys are
purple and brown
apparent ridges are different from
suggestive contours both produce
pleasing images but we find that
apparent ridges are more appealing in
many cases they produce more natural
images for facial features
and include law
in convex regions we're suggestive
contours cannot appear line drawings
look better when they are thresholded
appropriately here we compare successive
thresholding levels for the three
different feature lines
you